una emboscada mortal contra una nueva
unidad militar burkinesa dejó varios
muertos y desaparecidos incluidos tres
europeos dos españoles y un irlandés sam
hill 7 le parece que era su primera
misión enriquecer en un debemos es decir
que pasó en un lugar donde la carretera
estaba deteriorada significa que no
puedes manejar deprisa y habías
deterioradas con mucha vegetación son
lugares aptos para emboscadas son
desmontó y sus hábitats
la emboscada sucedió en una reserva
natural en la frontera entre burkina
faso y benin los atacantes que podrían
ser terroristas usaron dos camionetas y
una docena de motos según fuentes de
seguridad y aparentemente perseguían a
extranjeros para secuestrarlos la unidad
de 40 personas era parte de una nueva
fuerza contra la caza furtiva
un soldado burkinés todavía está
desaparecido mientras que la muerte de
los españoles y el irlandés ya se ha
confirmado el ciudadano irlandés era
ambientalista según medios del país y
los dos españoles eran periodistas
veteranos en zonas hostiles y de
conflicto estaban trabajando en un
documental sobre los operativos
a burkina faso para proteger los parques
naturales para proteger a sus recursos
naturales contra la caza furtiva esta es
una zona peligrosa por ser campo de
operación habitual de grupos terroristas
de furtivos de bandidos
y de grupos yihadistas estos grupos
algunos vinculados al qaeda o al grupo
estado islámico han causado una de las
mayores crisis de desplazamiento en la
región del sahel casi 3 millones de
personas han dejado sus hogares